good to see you again my friend nice to
see you i'm going to start with
something first of all congrats on
peacemaker i i was about to curse it is
very good oh thanks man thank you uh uh
but i'm friendly with matthew vaughn and
uh he told me he was really impressed
with your work on argyle um like really
like he gave you some like i was talking
to him and he gave you some he said some
very positive things about you so i just
have to ask you what was it like working
with him
uh man i i am a huge fan of his work i
don't know if there's a bigger he's
probably a bigger fan of uh kingsman
than me but i'm a huge fan
um
and
you know the the script was amazing and
to be able to be asked
to to be able to be part of a project
like that it's it's a dream come true i
i
we we talk a bunch it's almost every
time we talk i
express that i don't i don't know what
the hell is going on or why it's
happening and i'm just grateful for
every
everything that that is happening um
i
i don't know what to say it's it's a
it's a dream come true
sure uh he's all i mean i can't wait
because he does action and it's also
brad allen's last project for being the
action director but we'll talk about
that down the road um jumping into
peacemaker um what made you more nervous
when james told you about the opening
credits and what you'd be doing or the
entire fight sequence in your underwear
uh
both um
the the fight sequence in the underwear
had its
own set of setbacks i i love the fight
sequence and the underwear because
like what a what a symbol of
vulnerability and what a symbol of
humanizing um someone that we only
only see uh in a helmet uniform um
i love that aspect about it but then
then the negative is
no pad so like for the stunt falls uh
spencer thomas is an absolute stud he's
the guy who took a lot of the
the big stuff including uh jumping out
of a building but that's that area
is is about as close to a ring as you're
gonna get so i was also adamant about
wanting to do a whole lot of that fight
myself
and uh the only problem is you can't
grip on a hardwood floor and it's it
really hurts when you fall because
there's nowhere to hide any pad which is
a lot a lot of reason why you see actors
wear long sleeves the peacemaker short
sleeve costume in itself has a lot of
setbacks when it comes to doing
uh really difficult stunt work because
you just can't put pads on places you
try to land like your elbows your
shoulder for instance so your forearms
wrist um
the opening dance number uh
i can't dance so
i was nervous and like i'm not going to
be any good at this so
you you dive into that philosophical
question of uh am i enough being
self-aware enough to be like approach
the concept of well am i enough i'm not
going to be any good at this they're all
going to laugh at you to quote an adam
sandler sound bite um but i you know i i
i really enjoyed the concept of it and
it's super weird and everyone that sees
it is like yo
it made me just forget about the skip
intro button so
mission accomplished even and it was a
step to walk the talk hey this is
something you're not going to be good at
some you're going to have to work hard
at it's not going to be easy but
hopefully in the end it'll be okay and
it was
i've watched seven of the eight episodes
and each time the credits came on i just
had a big smile on my face because it's
so good you know what i mean um and also
the song by wigwim uh or wig uh wig
yeah yep and
i also think it it it changes in it's
it's um
it's clarity through throughout the
course of the episodes
uh sometimes it's like the john cena
horns the theme music because it's such
a big ballad and it just really starts
out like that and there are some times
where it's eerily
sad and melancholy for being such like a
weird ballad and the the tone of the
dance takes you on a different ride
because of what you just saw and what
you're about to see
so it has chameleon-like tendencies too
and i enjoy that about it yeah i told
james i asked him if there was an
extended version and he said no and i
was ready to rage quit the interview you
know i'm like
but anyway i think james squeezed all
the water out of that rock he could
it's so good though i can't wait for
people to see it um talk a little bit
about your relationship with eagley
because obviously it's amazing and fans
are going to love it and there is a lot
of emotion with a character you know
like uh i i just can you talk about the
relationship sure can i think it's it's
very important in a lot of dynamics
first of all he's a scene stealer no
doubt he uh he has personality and it's
quirky certainly more attitudinal
cat-like than dog-like
uh but cutting to the chase as far as
peacemaker's perspective eagerly is
peacemaker's best friend
and that says a lot about
the human connections that peacemaker
has allowed himself to have and i think
that explains a lot of why his world
view may be the way it is so
just in that
in that perspective alone i think eagle
is very important eagley like i said is
an integral part of the team and a scene
stealer
but is also peacemaker's best friend
which
is beautiful in some moments when you
get hugged by an eagle it's that's
magical man but also uh it says a lot
about you know peacemaker's life and how
he lives his life
um you obviously you play peacemaker on
the suicide squad it's a completely
different dynamic making a movie you
have sometimes days to film a sequence
when you're making peacemaker obviously
the schedule is way abbreviated and it's
much faster because it's a tv series
what was it like
playing peacemaker and making your first
series like this if you know what i mean
no it was a pleasure never once did it
feel rushed and and never once did we
fall behind even even you know
with the restrictions of covet and it
was right in the heart of all um
we everybody came prepared i think
everybody knew it was going to be um a
lot of work but it was work the entire
cast both on camera and behind the
camera the crew
everybody had fun with it started from
day one me dancing in my underwear and
it's kind of
it was a tidal wave after that um
[Music]
i i think that the main difference was
you got to see
a lightning bolt of the character in the
suicide squad and then you can kind of
stay for
an extended journey and really lean into
the character and i know the cool thing
about it is not everybody uh felt
positive about peacemaker after the
suicide squad a lot of folks were like
why are you giving this [ __ ] his own
show this guy is not a likeable dude uh
but i also find that interesting because
if you if you look deeper into the
performance of the suicide squad there
are
these micro second nuanced human moments
which shows potential potential for
growth potential for development
potential for exploration
which is really good when you're trying
to craft an 80 episode tv series
uh were you a little bit surprised at
the success of vacation friends
i was
i was uh i
had a blast making the movie i pretty
much got to be on vacation and enjoy
uh but comment comedy is tough it really
is and and what you think is funny
uh someone else may not think is funny
we got a great group of people to make
that movie uh clay tarber the director
and and uh
wrote the movie and
he's a funny sob and certainly rel and
yvonne and meredith and and uh everybo
everybody involved in the cast we got a
great group together we all had fun
making it uh
but man i'm
i'm so much more nervous
for comedy than i are than i am for
something like a superhero venture
because it's it's a lot more accepted of
like okay uh uniform super power
association with marvel or dc
i kind of get it whereas like hey
this is our funny
it's it's it's so
uh open for interpretation i i wasn't um
i was very pleasantly surprised with the
success of vacation friends because man
it was a bunch of fun
uh yeah that was that was a pleasant
surprise and i i know they're writing a
sequel and i can't wait to do another
one
exactly um listen man congrats on
everything uh uh i wish you nothing but
the best oh thank you it's good to talk
to you again